normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government first
story from abc27 voting machines in one
Pennsylvania county flip votes for
judges an error to be fixed in
tabulation I love this a quick
correction for the beginning of the show
I said it was in in one location
actually voting machines plural in a
county were flipping votes they check
this out they say voters were asked to
decide whether Pennsylvania Superior
Court judges Jack penella and and Victor
stabil should be retained for additional
10-year terms the yes or no votes for
each judge were being switched because
of the error said Lamont clure the
Northampton County Executive if a voter
marked yes to retain Panella and no for
example first a bill it was reflected as
no on Panella and yes on stabil or
however you pronounce that now look
they're saying it's going to be fixed
the question the first question I have
is what if no one noticed and more
importantly what if no one noticed
any others how how are we supposed to
this this is a huge huge problem because
right now voter confidence is probably
at an alltime low considering 2020 and
even 2022 midterms and now with this
it's not even this check we got a bunch
of other stories here we go let me see
if I have uh no no we're getting there
Nick sorder says one of the top five
most liberal voting precincts in
Kentucky has been cleared out due to a
supposed gas leak kentuckians are
currently at the polls voting to decide
whether or not they want to their democ
Governor Andy Basher and replace him
with trump-backed Daniel Cameron
Highland Baptist Church in Louisville
will now be having extended voting hours
after being shut down we have this one
two Jefferson County polls get extend
extended voting time after brief
shutdowns so uh this is also this is a
related story we're uh we're we're
basically getting a a it's not
confidence building now I'll say it
right like I'll say it like this I don't
know if this matters in the big picture
these singular individual voting events
I think uh uh let me clarify I don't
know if right now just this one thing
matters I think together however and the
bigger picture matters is what I'm
trying to say if you're getting stories
like this and people already don't trust
the system it is going to shock
confidence in our elections which means
it doesn't matter who wins if the
Democrat wins the Republicans are going
to point to these and if the Republican
wins the Democrats going to point to
these Democrats will say things like
Republicans were so salty about 2020
they started manipulating with machines
and rep going to say Democrats are here
doing the same thing they've been doing
I don't see when you look at what's
going on already and this not even the
biggest election day I mean come on the
primary voting is going to be Bonkers
we're I'm not even talking about you
know November 2024 the general what's
going to happen when people go to vote
in the primaries and they're getting
weird things happening what happens when
people go to vote in the primary and a
in a blue State's like oh whoopsie you
you didn't vote for Trump you voted for
Des santis or something like that what
you should do is immediately stop
release the software code of that
machine because they're calling it an
error and it was it an error or was it
supposed to do what it did yeah it's
it's really weird to me how people have
this very black and white view of voter
fraud it's like either it's not
happening at all and if you say it's
happening then you're an election denier
blah blah blah or it's like the whole
system is rigged and you might as well
not vote like of course voter fraud is
happening of course there are people
tampering Machines of course there are
people stuffing ballots we know this
people have been charged for this in the
past and as we're seeing if you look at
polls over time of where people are at
on the political Spectrum everyone is
pushing further to the fr
and as that happens people are going to
feel it is more of a life ore situation
to try to rig elections of course
they're going to feel that way oh yeah
if I change this machine I'm literally
saving trans lives or I am literally
saving the country from you know
whatever it might be so I think we
really need to be looking out for this
this doesn't mean don't vote at all if
anything I think the media are the
bigger election rigers than anyone in
this but um yeah there's a very
phenomenon happening more than we
probably know this is why you need to
make sure you go out and vote there's
two big things here one they want to
demoralize you for all you know like for
all the people who think there's a
conspiracy to steal votes maybe the real
conspiracy they want to convince you not
to vote I don't believe they can rig an
as every single machine yeah now see
this story this is really demoralizing
you mean even if I do go out and vote
they might flip my vote don't fall for
it don't fall for it because
they when I say they I'm talking about
your political opponents and I don't
care who they are it's establishment
neol neocon all of them all the people
playing dirty politics want to convince
you not to vote so that they can win
it's like that episode of South Park
where they're voting for The Giant
douche in the turd sandwich and then I
can't remember what happened I think
like Kyle goes to Stan and he's like you
got to vote and he's like okay I'll vote
I guess he's like awesome wait who are
you voting for like I'm voting for the
other guy no wait don't vote they want
to convince you to vote but if they find
out you're going to vote for their
opponent they don't want you to vote I
think if these machines or are flipping
votes intentionally the more people that
vote the more likely it's going to get
found out that they're flipping vot
votes so you should definitely vote and
pay close attention and be volunteering
like be involved in your local elections
be involved in your local community half
the people that are volunteering are
going to be these activist types that
are on welfare that don't have jobs that
have all the time in the world you go be
involved in that we should be at our
local elections we should be you know
the volunteers there because that's
going to be how you're going to spot
this
stuff 20 next year is going to be wild I
don't even I don't even know where to
begin with it the fact that like there's
a lack of uh trust in estab the
establishment essentially um is I think
that the the lack of belief in in v in
the the soundness of the of the
elections that's that's baked into the
distrust of the The Establishment and
the more we we see people that are
skeptical or that are cynical about
voting or about the system the more
you're going to have things like people
see essentially confirmation bias
they'll they'll see something that seems
anomalous or seems weird and then
they'll be like well I know it's
definitely this cuz all it takes is one
small thing for people to be like now
I'm I've seen enough to have my previous
opinions confirmed and so now it's it's
not a you know now the whole thing
should be thrown away and that's just a
a symptom of of having a A system that
people are very cynical about you know
people are extremely mistrusting of the
establishment media The Establishment
with when it comes to the government and
it's not just in the United States I
mean you guys were talking about what
Canada's like now and this is a
phenomenal yeah and this is a phenomenon
that's happening across basically the
whole of Western Society I I do think
what Lauren just said is consent to an
American invasion of Canada absolutely
well it would be of China you got to
wait you got to wait till Springtime all
right it's it's cold up there I just
want to let you know uh you do know the
founding fathers of the United States
went to you guys and said work with like
you you y'all were colonies too and our
guys were like you guys want to get in
on this and you were like nah we're
good we were burning down the White
House all right we still had a bit going
on for us British did we almost took
Montreal our ancestors saying did you
guys see the Canada election fraud stuff
with the Chinese interference no what
happines none of you guys we have like
had hard Lauren how many people live in
Canada like 30 something million how can
you guys not care about this you're
going to have a colony of China living
above you literally we're going to
remember when the Chinese Army went to
Canada and was like doing training
drills yeah literally and you guys don't
care about this when I was at the air
three hours your border is 3 hours from
my house in New Hampshire I damn well
care you know this yeah you should not
only were the ads the wait times for my
flights were all in chines like we're
Vancouver is becoming a Chinese majority
City right now and like people are
raising the Chinese Communist flag at
City Hall and police stations and stuff
it's kind of wild um but yeah we've
we've had a proven by Seas say our
intelligence agency Chinese influence
campaign in Canada to win the election
for liberals donations um they've put
out ads for students and in Chinese only
ads encouraging people that are Chinese
and Canada to vote for Liberal
politicians and it's been and honeypots
have been deployed cus confirmed that
against poit Maple pot syrup pots in
Canada sir but full-blown full-blown and
this is just like not being talked about
how our elections are literally being
happened in 2015 as well except it was
it was the us doing it in the 2015
election with Le things yeah liberal
though it was like deep State us it was
they put you know they they they helped
put uh you know James o' had a report
power James o had a report about uh
Chinese uh money flowing through act
blue I think you were something big
about that Lauren you were talking about
immigration is it is immigration you uh
largely from China in in Canada is that
the interesting we used to have a large
amount of his particular particularly BC
Vancouver from Hong Kong but it's
flipped it's like you know in the single
percentages for Hong Kong and it's
mostly mainland China now coming to BC
Vancouver they call it hongcouver you're
not supposed to say that out loud but
for you can't say anything up there it
when you literally have enclaves I was
getting my nails done at the airport
true story and the lady lives in
Richmond which is where the YVR Airport
is and she's like oh yeah I can't shop
at certain stores and she's not
particularly political she's just like
Richmond Richmond BC like Vancouver area
she's like yeah they just don't want me
shopping there cuz I'm white and I don't
speak the language the local language
you look at um complexes being built in
Richmond and all of the advertisements
for buying are in Chinese they're not in
English I could show you videos right
now all of the housing it's we are a
Chinese Colony at this point so what
what is the voter fraud angle oh well
China is directly influencing our
elections in Canada they are deploying
um ad campaigns they're deploying
honeypots uh they're involved in
offering tons of money to Liberal
politicians because they want to
continue to have large amounts of
control over our economy and um also
moneya laundering they call it snow
washing in Canada so tons of I think it
was um we have the same amount of moneya
laundering as uh the UK but we have
about a 3% success rate at uh actually
pursuing them legally compared to the UK
I've seen it from Al jazer this is from
September a couple months ago Canada
what was this say Canada opens inquiry
into allegations of election meddling by
China and Russia I also saw from
Bloomberg in
2021 uh China's alleged election
meddling creates problem for AP AP
reporting from September 2023 Chan
announces public inqu inquiry into
whether China Russia and others
interfered in elections yeah it's
there's a whole investigation into it
it's all confirmed the Glo it was I
think a lot of it was broken by global
no it wasn't Global it was uh mlan I
can't remember Americans see here's what
happens in the uh revolutionary era the
re the era of Independence the United
States there it wasn't just 13 colonies
everyone says the original 13 colonies
but they don't realize that British
colonies actually go extend up into
Canada there's many of them and the
founding fathers the same negotiations
they're having with say Florida or or or
South Carolina whatever are the same
negotiations they're having with Quebec
another British colony well up north the
Canadian what is now Canada was like
we're not interested in declaring
independence you're on your own so it's
a bunch of British colonies and only
some of them declared independence so I
think what you see here is the United
States more has more uh uh descendants
of of rebels it it was a there were more
people here who were rebellious and
willing to fight and die for
Independence than in Canada absolutely
Canada ends up with more people who are
willing to play ball they're more
willing to say look look I don't want to
get into a fight and this opens the door
to heavy soft power from say China or
Russia what are gun rights like in China
or in China what are in China I want to
make one more comment you know what the
most depressing part of all of this is I
don't even get my scam calls in English
anymore oh I'm like that's true in
United States too my good friend scam
likely calls very often and it always
leaves you a message you know that guy
too yeah scam what's he up to scam
likely that's his name you guys know
telemarketer they're always in Chinese
I'm like they they actually expect when
they call a Vancouver like phone number
they're like oh we're more likely to
reach a Chinese person than
mandin I need to clearly you know what I
think that is I think that the uh this
is a big problem in the United States
and in North America in general where
we're all getting these random phone
calls it's been ongoing for a long time
when you answer it you get an automated
machine saying something in in Mandarin
you can't understand but understand this
for you as an individual having a minute
or two of distraction it's no big deal
with to your life but for the entire
country China can calculate the macro
level when we run these Bots to pH to
call 7 million people per day we depress
the US economy by 0.2% or something like
this it is the macro effect as an
individual you don't care but on the
whole it could be massive I describe it
like Blackjack you know at the table for
the time it's basically a coin toss
between you and the house but that 05%
edge over the year means the casino will
make money same thing for China doing
these scam calls well you know what it
does too it makes people never pick up
phone calls you get a you get a call
from a business that's actually like
involved in your life and your community
wanting you to come out you're not
answering that no one answers their
phone we were just talking about this
this morning we don't answer our phones
anymore I don't I don't even have my
ringer on I keep my ringer off did you
guys hear about what happened with the
banks no that past week all these
different banks had payroll disruption
mhm and people think it's like oh so I
didn't get my paycheck for a few hours
was kind of annoying hold on let's say a
million people are in their paycheck
right when they wake up instead they get
it at 400 p.m. how many of these people
living to paycheck to paycheck had a
bill that was due that day thing
happened in Canada uh few months ago
with TD they they miss payroll and I
mean and there's people who are moving
into new homes and you know rent I think
trau even had to do a statement about it
and then what they they charge people
overdraft fees that W that's Insidious
if a bank can't give you your payroll
they cannot charge you an good luck they
don't
care use your Second Amendment right
your First Amendment right you
know the sixth Bank the sixth Bank this
year just collapsed in the United States
uh was it like Iowa savings and loan or
something like that just collapsed I got
to ask so the the American colonies
split off from the the Canadian colonies
U long 250 years ago what what are gun
rights like in Canada from then to now
what have they what what was the what
was the establishment existence of
weapons rights there's you know it's
been pretty good but there's this short
period um when a certain politician got
elected that they all seem to disappear
overnight I can't true Trudeau right
yeah no immediately as he came in like
2020 they got rid of AKs m4s M16s 1,500
weapons like all overnight gone um added
to restricted can't buy anymore and then
after the Uvalde shooting because of
course Uvalde is in Canada and uh this
really affects us and the gun used was
definitely a gun that's legal in Canada
and not one that doesn't even uh any
made no sense he banned handguns uh
while we were filming the documentary
infringed so you can't purchase transfer
them anymore and this is going to keep
happening over and over they're floating
bills to ban things like the Plinkster
which is literally like you know to
shoot tin cans and they're talking about
banning these guns if Trudeau and the
Liberals stay in for another you know
they win the next election thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 pm and become a
member over at
timcast.net thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all next
time